jonathan is in Dallas Texas hi Jonathan
how are you
good day very doing better than I
deserve what's up well I have a question
for you in regards to a vehicle that I
recently had a repossession on about the
vehicle about four years ago
ridiculously high interest rate I
couldn't afford the car basically and
about six months ago like it was
repossessed and I haven't received any
information from the the bank in regards
to what the next step in the process is
and my newly married wife we just got
married a couple weeks ago we're looking
over our debts and trying to figure out
which one we should attack first if we
should if we should hold off on paying
off everything else and focus and on
saving up some money to maybe settle
with this a repo or if we should go on
and work on the rest of our debt at the
time of the repossession what was the
car worth the car the car was worth
Kelly Blue Book private sale $1500 okay
and what was owed against it about 7,000
okay and so you have a potential deficit
of fifty five hundred plus or minus then
that you could probably settle for a
couple thousand bucks what other debts
have you got I have about seven thousand
and student ones she has about six
thousand in credit cards and your
household income is what fifty eight
thousand okay
no they haven't contacted you at all yet
I would probably just work your debt
snowball and as soon as you finish it
put enough extra in your emergency fund
as you're building in and baby step
three to take care of this when it comes
up you should be able to settle this for
like two or three thousand bucks okay
yeah and I did just recently check my
credit and it did say that the debt was
a charge-off or bad debt doesn't matter
oh I didn't know that doesn't doesn't if
that doesn't take away their ability to
collect it it says there that is they
just labeled you as a deadbeat that's
all that means
yeah okay then they were you know you
have a repo and you have a bad debt
associated with repo that would be
normal on your credit bureau report it
just sounds like they're not very
efficient at their follow up in their
collection procedures yeah it was it's
it was form from a bank that actually
sciences people with poor credit and
basically charges ridiculous high
interest rates and everything so I was
just wondering if if that's something I
should be worried about getting you know
wages garnished or well they would have
to sue you before they could do that and
before they sue you they'll call you
okay just as a matter of practice it's a
lot easier for them so I mean they're
you're not going to get your wages going
to shoot out of the Adam I mean did you
change cities or anything um I did move
up about a year ago when I wanted to
move closer to my now wife ever since
the repo no no okay so they know where
you are then yes sir okay they'll find
you believe me when it's time and if
they don't find you by the time you get
around to them at the bottom of this
thing call them and tell them you want
to work out a settlement and get rid of
the problem and then whatever you do be
sure you get it in writing because as
you know you're dealing with punks these
high interest rates subterranean
subprime vehicle loans this is the Dave
Ramsey show